قناهم ولا يحيطون بشيء من علمه الا بما
شاء وسيم الكرسيه والسماوات والارضنا
الله اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله وعلى اله واصحابه
اجمعين
اما
‏con
examination theeview the contemplation
and we have expلق
which is the first chapter firstes of
more are firstes ofران
صلى الله عليه وسلم
خديجه
خديجه رضي الله عنها
ورقه
ابن نوفل
ابن اسد ابن عبد العزه
خديجه
ورقه رضي الله عنه
blind
was an of
among and people
becauseav
[Silence]
ره في الجاهليه
‏was someage
chr he was
of ch
and wasing
and some nar
that wasing
that wasent
inrew
andic
and wasate in all of those langages
التوراه
الانجيل
could find
صلى الله عليه وسلم ورقه
ورقه
هذا الناموس
الذي انزله الله على موسى
الله سبحانه وتعالى
موسى
عليه السلام
and
onlyend
to him
يا ليتني كنت فيها جدعا
يا ليتني اكون حيا اذ يخرجك قومك
اذ يخرجك قومك
days
قال او مخرجيهم
قال لم يجا لم يجئ رجل قط بمثل ما جئت به
الا عودي
peoplecept
[Silence]
وان يدركني يومك انصرك نصرا مؤزرا
in mying
عائشه رضي الله عنها
فلم يلبث ورقه ان توفي
صلى الله عليه وسلم خديجه انق
ورقه
وف الوحي
[Silence]
ورقه
خديجه
ملم
ابو بكر
مسلم عليم
زيد
ورقه
حديث
ورقه نوفل
الله
صلى الله عليه وسلم
ورقه
‏other
eteved
prop
however was not a messenger
he was a prop and appo
اقرا باسم ربك الذي خلق
يا ايها المدثر
ان شاء الله تعالى
فتره
قران
علم الانسان ما لم يعمل ما لم يعلم
صلى الله عليه وسلمر
فتره الوحي
فمنهم من قائل
فتره الوحي كانت اياما
ومنهم من يذكر سنوات كما ذكر ابن سعد ان
فتره الوحي كانت ثلاث سنين ثلاث سنوات
لكن هذا لا يعني
انه لم ياته جبريل في هذه الفتره كلها
اصحاب هذا القول الذين يقولون
بطول فتره الوحي وان فتره الوحي كانت سنين
فليس مقصد قولهم انه لم ياته جبريل قطاه
جبريل بالاجماع وانما يقصد اصحاب هذا
القول ان
القران والفتره كانت في نزول القران
ليس في نزول جبريل عليه السلام والا فاتاه
كثيرا ومرارا
some
kindার
اقرا باسم ربك الذي خلق يا ايها المدثر
‏time
by the opion
is
not come for years and this is that was
mentioned and opion
came to him a number of times butelation
الذي قال به ابن عباس وغيره
ان فتره الوحي كانت اياما
اياما ثلاثه ايام خمسه ايام اسبوع عشره
ايام شيء نحو هذا
اتيتمنت
عباس رضي الله عنهما
days
up to 10 days was days more
this time
paused
and this time
ى عليه وسلم
to himself andallyysicallyception
of theing ofation
in order to contempate the words thated
to him in order to
‏prop صلى الله عليه وسلم
حراضان
only رمضان
فتره الوحي
الله اقرا باسم ربك الذي خلق
نايت القدر ليله القدر انا انزلناه
في ليله القدر انا انزلناه في ليله مباركه
ليله القدر
second رمضان
جابر بن عبد الله
بخاري مسلم
جابر رضي الله عنه ساد سمعت رسول الله صلى
الله عليه وسلم يقول جاورت بحراء
يعني رجع الى حراء بعد
الوحي الاول رجع ليتم اعتكافه في حراء كما
كانت عادته
قال فهبطت حتى استبطنت الوادي وهو مقفل
الى اهله
فسمعت صوتا
فنظرت عن يميني وعن شمالي وامامي ومن خلفي
فلم ارى شيئا
فرفعت بصري فاذا الملك الذي جاءني بحراء
جالس على كرسي بين السماء والنور بين
السماء والارض وفي روايه
ايه كرسي من نور بين السماء والارض فجؤثت
منه فرقا
يعني وقعت على الارض من الخوف
ثم رجعت
الى اهلي فقلت دثروني دثروني وصبوا علي
ماء باردا
فدثروني
وصبوا علي ماء باردا
ثم اوحى الله الي يا ايها المدثر
قم فانذر وربك فكبر
وثيابك فطهر
والرجز فاهجر ولا تمنن تستكثر
ولربك فاصبر هذه الايات
ان صحيح البخاري ان صحيح مسلم
ذا بروفيت صلى الله عليه
حراء
حراراء
جبريل ان اقرا باسم ربك الذي خلق انقن
نوفل
حراضان
said after
my
‏and as I was on my home
I a
I looked in front of me and behind me
and to my right and to my left I didn't
see anything
and then he raised his eyes to the sky
above him he looked
[Silence]
في بعض الروايات على عرش
صلى الله عليه وسلم
and
saidوني
دثروني
خديجه رضي الله عنها
جبريل عليه
سوره المدثر
يا ايها المدثر
قم فانر
وربك فكبر
وثيابك فطهر
ان شاء الله
والرجز فهج
ولا تمن تستكثر
ولربك فاصبر
صلى الله عليه وسلمخاري مسلم
قال جابر ثم حمي الوحي وتتابع يرويه عن
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
very
much wasent
نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى بمنه وكرمه وجوده
ان يفقهنا جميعا في كتابه وفي دينه نساله
سبحانه وتعالى ان يعلمنا من كتابه ما
جهلنا وان يذكرنا منه ما نسينا وان يعلمنا
الحكمه منه نساله سبحانه وتعالى بمنه
وكرمه وجوده ان يجعلنا نعيش ايامنا في
الدنيا مع رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
وصحابته
وائمه الاسلام وعامتهم الصالحين نساله
سبحانه وتعالى ان يجمعنا بينهم يوم
القيامه بين يديه بين يدي عرشه العظيم وصل
اللهم وسلم على نبينا محمد وعلى اله
واصحابه اجمعين والحمد لله رب العالمين
وجزاكم الله ‏Yeah.